Welcome to this lecture
on the basics of
diagnosing the nominates
and ***** bone.
Here are today's
session objectives.
Please note that today's
lecture is to introduce
you to the screening
tests that are used
to answer the question
of whether there may
be somatic dysfunction
in the pelvis, in
other words, in nominate
or ***** somatic
dysfunctions. However,
this lecture will not be
covering the individual
somatic dysfunctions.
Those will be covered
in a later lecture.
Here's today's outline.
I will introduce the
static landmarks at
the very end in order
for you to get a little
bit of a head start
but will not go into
how you use the various
landmarks in order
to ultimately make a
pelvic somatic dysfunction
diagnosis. That will
be covered separately
in a lab prep lecture
and lab portion on the
pelvis. Please also
review the practice
questions at the end to
test your understanding
of today's lecture.
The following 14 slides
are to give you an
overview of some
of the functional
significance of the
pelvis and hopefully give
you a better understanding
and appreciation
of this region and
help you to understand
why we would even
be interested in
diagnosing somatic
dysfunction in the pelvis.
Aim to understand
the general points
in these slides,
but you do not
have to worry about
memorizing specific
details of the
anatomy presented.
We begin by recalling
that the nominate
bone comes in three
parts at birth,
the ileum, ischium,
and *****. And these
parts come together
at the acetabulum,
where the head of
the femur resides.
Recalling this is useful
because in an adult,
one often considers
the nominate bone
as a whole, but it's
important to understand
that they have origins
in three parts, and
also somatic dysfunction
can be specifically
identified as it
relates to the ilium,
the ischium, and
the ***** bones.
Joints allow for
mobility. Two of the most
significant joints
in the body in terms
of their role in
structural support and
mobility, as well as
the significant amount
of forces that go
through the region are
the SI joints, abbreviated
here as the SIJ.
In males, the ligaments
of the sacroiliac
joints are particularly
well developed
and strong. In females,
in addition to the
need for structural
integrity, there is
also a need for relative
laxity of the pelvic
sacroiliac joint
ligaments. This is due
to the need for the
pelvic girdle to adapt
in shape during
pregnancy and delivery.
The motion at the SI
joints is more and
more limited as one
ages. Keep in mind
also that the sacroiliac
joint has a slight
L-shape or a C
-shape, and that can
influence the biomechanics
of the region.
Anteriorly, the
***** symphysis
is a fibrocollagenous
joint.
This means that there
is some mobility
that occurs in
this region, and
hence somatic
dysfunction can also
occur at this region
as it also does
at the sacroiliac
joint posteriorly.
These diagrams illustrate
the anterior and
posterior sacroiliac
joint ligaments. Make
note of their density
and just sheer amount
as well as their varying
orientation. This
should give you an
idea of the significant
amount of forces they
must be able to withstand
as well as the directions
of these forces.
This is understandable
given that the pelvis
connects the lower
extremities to the
spine and provides a
foundation for body support
and locomotion. The
motion that occurs
around the SI joints and
***** symphysis occurs
during among other
things the gait cycle
during flexion and
extension of the spine.
Side bending and
rotation also impact the
sacroiliac joints and
the sacroiliac joint
as mentioned earlier
also needs to conform
to the needs of
pregnancy and childbirth.
Next, we move on to
the muscles of the
pelvic floor. These
muscles provide
support for the
contents of the lower
abdomen and the pelvic
floor, sometimes
referred to as the
pelvic diaphragm.
There are various
muscles that comprise
this region, two of
which are the levator
ani and the coccygeus.
This does not mean
to imply that
these are the most
important, but definitely
they are among the
muscles that we need
to consider when it
comes to issues such
as low back pain or
pelvic floor dysfunction
or pelvic pain.
The pelvic wall
also consists of the
piriformis and
obturator internus.
Again there are numerous
muscles to speak
about so this is just
a highlight of these
regions that we might
want to consider.
I would like to
now highlight some
muscles that are
important for the lumbar
and pelvic region.
The muscles of the
trunk and extremity
allow for a locomotion.
The abdominal muscles
in conjunction
with the lumbar
spine muscles are
important for core
stability and mobility.
The quadrice lumborum
has its origin
in the 12th rib and
inserts into the
posterior iliac crest.
And as you might
recall from the
lumbar lecture, it is
important for actions
such as ipsilateral
side bending as
well as extension.
And it has an
important role in low
back pain and
pelvic complaints.
The ilial psoas which
actually consists
of the psoas major
and the iliacus
muscles are important
in low back pain,
hip and pelvic and
groin symptoms also.
This is because
not only is it
important for hip
flexion but it is an
important stabilizer
of the lumbar spine.
Here we have a view of
the anterior musculature
of the low
extremities. One can
appreciate the predominantly
superior inferior
orientation of the
muscle fibers but there
is some medial lateral
orientation also hence
the differential
pull and function of
these muscles can impact
the forces that are
sensed in the pelvis
because of the attachments
of these muscles
or some of these
muscles to the pelvis
and also how to make this
function in pelvis by
potentially impacting
the lines of forces,
for example, may
impact the function of
the low extremities.
The comments just
made for the anterior
musculature also
apply to the posterior
musculature of the
low extremities.
Although not shown
in this diagram,
the gluteus maximus is
an important muscle.
It's a powerful
extensor of the hip,
so actions such as
going from a seated to
standing position
requires optimal
functioning of the
gluteus maximus for that
function to be smooth
and efficient. Of
course, in the case of
going from seated to
standing, that also
requires contraction
of the quadriceps in
order to extend at
the knees. So it's
always important to
understand how different
muscles combine
in order to achieve
a particular action.
The hamstrings are
described here and are
important for the
function of knee flexion.
Next, I wish to just
briefly consider
the nervous system.
This of course does
not do it justice
given the important
role of the nervous
system in sensory,
autonomic, and
locomotive function.
We can look at the
diagram and in a way
imagine how the pelvic
girdle serves as a
scaffolding of sorts
for the nervous tissue.
We have the sacrosympathetic
trunk, which
are extensions of the
lumbar sympathetic
chain ganglia. These
fuse over the coccyx
to form the single
ganglion impar. We
have the parasympathetic
nerves of the
pelvic splatonic region
that arise off the
ventral rami of the
S2 to S4 region, and
these supply the
parasympathetic innervation
to the left colon and
inferior hypogastric
plexus. The inferior
hypogastric plexus
is both parasympathetic
and sympathetic
in nature, and there
are smaller plexi that
innovate the ******,
bladder, prostate,
uterus, and vagina,
and hence its important
role in autonomic
function of the organs.
Earlier I mentioned
the performance
as one of the
muscles of the
pelvic wall. In
this diagram,
it's shown various
anatomical variations.
In a small percentage
of the population,
the sciatic nerve
actually pierces through
the piriformis muscle.
But more generally
speaking, if there's
anatomical shifts in
the relationship between
a sacrum and anominate
bone and hip, such
as from somatic
dysfunction, if there
is anatomical variation
as shown here, or if
there's spasm of the
piriformis muscle, as
well as other muscular
structure is not
shown here, then that
can lead to potential
irritation of the
sciatic nerve and lead
to symptoms such as
buttock pain or hip or
lower extremity pain,
and even altered function
of lower extremities,
such as motor
weakness, for example.
Next, we consider
the viscera. While
it's true that the
nervous system plays
a significant role
in the function of
the viscera it's
also important to
consider that the
pelvis for example is a
container for the
pelvic organs and
hence the bony and
myofascial structures
and any aberrations
potentially can impact
the function of these
organs such as their
circulation and lymphatic
drainage and even
do interactions with
the nerves impact the
autonomic function of
these various organs
fascial condensations
or thickenings of the
myofascial support
structures are called
anatomically as
ligaments and these carry
blood vessels and nerves
so one has to always
consider the entire
package that not only
do these ligaments help
support these various
structures but they
actually are important
for the physiology
of these structures
and therefore because
ligaments have attachments,
not just to the
organs, but also to
potentially to bony
structures, that aberrations
in the bony structures
of the pelvis
can influence the
function of these organs.
And hence, it's
important to consider the
role of somatic
dysfunction and treatment
in order to optimize
organ function.
Although the
abdominal diaphragm
is the main driver
for respiration
and must work in
coordination with
other structures.
For the pelvis,
the abdominal and
pelvic diaphragms
must work together
in order to properly
deliver blood,
oxygen, and nutrients
to the various
tissues and will
properly remove waste
products through
the venous and
lymphatic circulation.
Hence,
optimal pelvic
motion free from
any restriction
is important
for proper
physiologic function.
During a gait cycle,
the sacroiliac joint
has to sustain weight
and transfer motion
from the feet to the
rest of the body.
The physiologic
motions of the
sacrum and ilia
occur around
various theoretical
axes of motion.
So magdysfunction
affecting any of these
axes can hinder
the gait, require
compensatory changes both
locally in the pelvis,
sacrum, and lumbar
spine region as
well as potentially
the rest of the body.
This can impact
functions such as speed,
stride length,
the rhythm of
the gait, and can
lead to symptoms
such as pain,
balance issues,
and even can
alter energy expenditure.
During pregnancy,
due to the mechanical
demands of carrying
a growing fetus
as well as hormonal
changes, the relationship
of the pelvis and
sacrum change.
The center of
gravity shifts
anteriorly, the
sacroiliac joints and the
***** symphysis
become more lax.
There's also an increase
in the lumbar and
cervical lodoses, the
thoracic kyphosis, as
well as an increase
in the anterior pelvic
tilt, meaning that both
enominate bones rotate
anteriorly. These
changes are necessary,
however they can lead
to symptoms such as
pain or low back tightness,
and therefore being
able to diagnose
and treat somatic
dysfunction in the lumbar
and pelvic regions, for
example, is quite
useful during pregnancy.
This slide is a
reminder that when we
say somatic
dysfunction, we are also
referring to the various
components of the
body, the skeletal,
arthrodial, myofascial,
and their related
vascular lymphatic
and neural elements.
In other words,
there may be
positional asymmetry or
restricted motion,
but in terms of what's
actually going on,
there can be quite
more, as described
by this definition.
Therefore, it's
important to read
into the tissue,
so to speak, and
understand that
whatever we diagnose in
terms of the
criteria for somatic
dysfunction, meaning
the tarte changes,
that there could
be accompanying
physiologic changes.
Please keep in mind
that our evaluation of
the pelvis and its
related structure, the
sacrum, begins with
the history. In other
words, the chief
complaint and then the
details of the history
of peasant illness,
past medical history,
and so on. The goal
of treatment is to
restore structural
relationship and function
between the various
components of the
body, therefore
addressing both symptoms
as well as function.
Here's a photograph
of the front of
Grand Central
Station in Manhattan.
We can imagine that if
this were the pelvis
then the various
architectural components
of the structure
would be comparable
to the various landmarks
that we look for
in the pelvis when
trying to diagnose it.
Here we can still
see the facade or the
front of Grand Central
terminal. However,
from a bird's eye view,
we can see there's
much more to it. So if
we think of the pelvis
and the entire pelvic
structure, both
anteriorly as well as
posteriorly, one can
appreciate that just
like the pelvis, this
building is really a
container. It's three
-dimensional. It has an
anterior, posterior,
as well as lateral
aspects and an interior
aspect. We can appreciate
the ventilation
system that's on the
top. So one can think
of this for example as
the vessels and even
nervous system like
the wiring that goes
with the ventilation
system for example so
the point i'm trying
to make is that when we
look for somatic
dysfunction going back to
the definition there
are many more components
to it so it's always
important for us
to appreciate that when
we diagnose asymmetry
and hopefully treat
it adequately with
OMT that we are also
restoring the functionality,
the internal
architecture, if you will,
of what is contained
within the pelvis.
Here I have listed
the basic steps for
osteopathic structure
examination of the pelvis.
However, what is not
listed here is equally
important, and these
include the static
posture exam, looking
at the front, back, and
side aspects of the
person. For example, if
they come in limping
or hunched over at the
waist or unable to bend
sideways at the lumbar
spine, this already
gives you an idea of
what might be going on
in the pelvis and will
probably prompt further
examination beyond
just structure
examination of the pelvis.
We begin the pelvic
exam with the
standing flexion
test, then progress to
the supine and prone
static examination,
and finally looking
at various landmarks
to arrive at a
structural somatic
dysfunction diagnosis
of the pelvis.
The first and
primary test for
screening the pelvis
for somatic dysfunction
is the standing
flexion test.
By somatic dysfunction
I am referring to a
nominate somatic
dysfunction or ***** bone
somatic dysfunction or
both. This test does
not give us the specific
diagnosis, but it
does clue us in to the
possibility that there
could be somatic
dysfunction in the pelvis.
It is basically
testing for restrictive
movement of the pelvis,
meaning the nominate,
relative to the
sacrum on a particular
side. Now there is
the possibility that
both sides are
dysfunctional. However,
typically even if
that were true,
typically one side
would be more restricted
than the other side,
and therefore the
test will still reveal
itself on one side.
To perform this
test, the patient is
initially standing
fully upright at the
waist, which is not
shown on the photo.
The feet, however,
are shoulder
width apart as
shown in this photo.
The provider is
standing behind the
patient and places
the thumbs over the
PSIS on each side,
so bilaterally.
It's important
to keep the eye
over the patient's
midline and
at about the
level of the PSIS.
The provider can be
standing as
shown or seated.
The patient is
then instructed to
slowly bend forward
at the waist.
What this does
is it carries the
sacral base forward,
meaning the top
of the sacrum
forward into flexion.
And eventually, this
motion through the
SI joint is carried
to the ilium, or the
nominate, which also
rotates anteriorly.
Because the PSIS is
part of the nominate
bone, when this
happens, eventually
the thumbs will
move cephalad and
slightly anterior,
because again, the
torso is flexing. But
we are looking for
which thumb moves
first and farthest.
So this might seem
counterintuitive
initially because if
there is restricted
movement, then why
would we be looking
for the thumb that
moves further?
This is because
when the sacrum
bends forward, as the
patient bends forward,
if the SI joint,
meaning the sacroiliac
joint is moving
freely, then there
will be a lag period
before that motion
is transmitted to the
nominate bone to
also bring it into
anterior rotation.
When it is restricted,
then it's as though
that sacroiliac joint
on a particular side
becomes more as a unit.
So when the patient
bends forward, then
as the sacrum bends
forward, then the
nominate bone on that side
will also bend forward
first and farther
than the other side.
Therefore, a positive
standing flexion
test reveals a restriction
of the sacroiliac
joint at about the
axis that determines
the movement of
the ilium relative
to the sacrum.
Hence, it is
specific for
ileosacral dysfunction,
In other words, pelvic
somatic dysfunction.
Here's a posted
review of how the
provider's thumbs are
placed over each PSIS.
Again, it's
important to keep the
dominant eye of the
provider over the
midline of the
patient's body at
about the same
level as the PSIS's.
Even before the test,
while the patient
is initially standing
upright at the waist,
we can determine
if there is some
asymmetry in terms of
one PSIS being more
cephalad or caudad
compared to the other.
It's important to
have good technique.
Typically, this means
that with your partner's
permission, you
will be placing the
thumbs over the skin
so you can maximally
appreciate the bony
surface of the PSIS.
The thumbs are also
horizontal as shown and
it's important to also
keep the same part
of the thumb pad over
the same part of the
PSIS generally it's
advisable to place the
thumbs on the inferior
aspect of the PSIS
meaning the inferior
slope of the PSIS because
as the patient bends
forward there's a
tendency of the thumbs
to roll over the PSIS and
therefore to come
off of that structure
therefore for making
the test less reliable.
So by having the
thumb pads placed
on the inferior
slope of each PSIS,
and making sure that
we stay on that bony
contact as the
patient bends forward,
then one can have a
more reliable test
and a more accurate test.
Here's a written
summary of
the standing
flexion test.
As I described earlier,
the test is positive
on the side where
your thumb placed over
the PSIS moves first
and farthest. Typically
the thumb that moves
first is also the
thumb that moves farther
than the other side.
So practically
speaking the thumb that
moves further meaning
more cephalat is
the positive side
but you can practice
this on your own and
pay attention and
to see for yourself
if this is indeed
the case where the
thumb that moves first
is also the thumb
that moves farther.
You can think
of the standing
flexion test as the
initial or entry
test to diagnosing
the pelvis.
There are two important
points to keep
in mind though.
Number one, a positive
test does not tell
you what the specific
somatic dysfunction is.
In order to arrive
at that, you will
need to look at the
specific patterns
of asymmetries in
the various landmarks
that you will
learn about in the
future in order to
come up with the
specific somatic
dysfunction diagnosis.
Keep in mind that
there could be more
than just one type of
somatic dysfunction
in the pelvis, and
this is common in
practice and not
just for the pelvis.
The second point
to keep in mind is
that sometimes the
test is positive,
yet you do not
find actual public
somatic dysfunction.
So in other
words, the test is
falsely positive.
This applies to many
tests, not just the
standing flexion
test, so keep in mind
this concept of a
false positive test.
How do you know
it's falsely
positive? If you end
up, again, looking
for pelvic somatic
dysfunction
and you do not
end up finding it.
There are various
reasons for a falsely
positive standing flexion
test, and it's not the
intent of this lecture
to go into that, but
one possibility is
that there is somatic
dysfunction elsewhere
in the body because the
body is interconnected
and that somatic
dysfunction, for example
muscle tension or
imbalance, ends up
affecting the sacroiliac
joint motion in such a
way that the standing
flexion test is positive,
yet it is actually
not caused by a pelvic
somatic dysfunction.
Second screening
test that we can use
and should use to
screen the pelvis for
somatic dysfunction is
the ASIS compression
test, also known
as the pelvic
rock test, or the
pelvic rock for short.
This test can
indicate iliosacral or
sacroiliac dysfunction.
Therefore, it
is not specific
for iliosacral
dysfunction. The
structure being tested is
the same. It is the
sacroiliac joint.
However, the
interpretation is
different or
potentially different.
To perform this test,
the heels of the
provider's hands are
placed over each ASIS
and pressure is applied
in a mostly posterior
but also slightly
medial direction to
aim towards the
sacroiliac joint. Note how
the vector or force
closely matches the
angle of the plane of
the sacroiliac joint.
One side is pressed
on and then the other
side and a comparison
is made to determine
how much movement
there is as well as
the firmness or laxity
of the resistance
when the end of the
movement is reached.
So for a normal
sacroiliac joint, the
amount of movement is
typically very slight
and it's more one
of assessing the
degree of resistance
that one encounters.
And as with any test,
the more one performs
this test, then the
more one is able to
gauge how abnormal the
test is and to be able
to determine if one
side is more abnormal
compared to the other.
For example, if there's
a positive standing
flexion test on the
left and a positive
ASIS compression test
on the right, then the
simplest interpretation,
but definitely
not the only interpretation,
but the simplest
interpretation would
be that there is a
pelvic somatic
dysfunction on the left,
meaning the side of the
standing flexion test,
and a sacroiliac
dysfunction on the right,
on the side of the
ASIS compression test.
In practice, if one
has a discrepancy, then
the first step would
be logically to
perform both tests again
to make sure that we
are consistent. And
then if they still
disagree, then make a
determination of what
the ASIS compression
test truly indicates.
Sometimes we don't
know, and one would
have to go through
the full diagnosis
of the endominates
as well as the
sacrum to cover
both possibilities,
perform any treatment,
and reassess
these areas,
including performing
the standing
flexion test and
the ASIS compression
test again.
Here is a written
description
of the ASIS
compression test.
Again, we are
assessing the
sacroiliac joints
one side at a time.
There should be
relatively gentle pressure
but still firm enough
to be able to test the
sacroiliac joints.
Please do not confuse
sacroiliac joint with
sacroiliac dysfunction.
The structure is the
sacroiliac joint,
whether it is iliosacral
dysfunction or sacroiliac
dysfunction. The
dysfunctions relate or
refer to the motion
of the ilium relative
to the sacrum or the
sacrum relative to the
ilium. And I will have
a slide in a moment
that will clarify that
point. We name the
positive side for the
side that offers more
resistance and less
motion. That's not written
here, but typically
the side that has more
resistance is also
the side that has less
motion. But the most
reliable measure,
because motion is typically
very slight anyway,
the most reliable
measure is the degree of
resistance that one
encounters. So significant
resistance on one
side compared to the
other side indicates
that there's a positive
test on the side of
increased resistance.
Now we come to the
C-deflection test.
this test is specific
for sacroiliac
dysfunction so this is
actually a test then
not for diagnosing
the pelvis meaning
a nominate somatic
dysfunction or *****
somatic dysfunction
however i present
it here because you
will be soon encountering
this test when
you learn about the
sacrum so i want to
present it here to
contrast it with the
standing flexion
test and so that you
also get an early
exposure to this test.
This test is testing
for sacroiliac
motion, and therefore,
if it's positive,
it indicates
sacrosomatic dysfunction.
The seated
flexion test is
performed seated,
hence the name.
The details, however,
are otherwise the
same as the standing
flexion test. The
provider places
the thumbs over the
PSIS's and as I had
recommended earlier,
typically it's best
to place them on the
inferior slope of
the PSIS. The patient
is asked to bend
forward slowly at
the waist and the
provider looks for the
thumb that moves
first and farthest and
names that side as
the positive side.
Because the patient
is seated, the
mechanics of the
motion at the
sacroiliac joint are
slightly different.
And the rotation,
even though it still
involves flexion of the
sacrum and anterior
rotation of the pelvis
in this test, the axis
of motion is slightly
different. And
therefore, it's assessing
for sacroiliac motion,
meaning movement of
the sacrum relative
to the pelvis. Another
way to think of it is
because the patient
is seated and therefore
stabilizing the pelvic
bones and the feet
are planted on the
floor also which adds
to this stability the
pelvis is relatively
stable not completely
stable but relatively
stable and therefore
as the patient bends
forward one is assessing
movement of the
sacrum relative to the
pelvis hence sacroiliac
motion and if it's
positive test, then that
signals the presence
of some form of
sacrosomatic dysfunction.
Here's a quick
summary that both
shows the similarities
and differences
between these two tests.
As I indicated
earlier, this slide
is to help you
distinguish between
ileosacral versus
sacroiliac motion.
Iliosacral, meaning
pelvic motion,
refers to the motion
of the ilium relative
to the sacrum along
the SI joint. The
theoretical axis of
motion is the inferior
transverse axis which
is designated by the
number three in the
diagram on the right.
Sacroiliac motion
however refers to the
motion of the sacrum
relative to the ilium.
The theoretical axis
of motion is the
middle transverse axis
designated by number
two in the diagram.
Notice how this
axis is both superior
as well as anterior
compared to the
inferior axis about
which iliosacral
motion occurs.
Please take a few moments
to review this slide.
While beyond the
scope of this talk,
I want to share
a few clinical
pointers when it comes
to the importance
of pelvic diagnosis
in practice.
The following slides
will introduce
the various landmarks
that are used
to diagnose pelvic
somatic dysfunctions.
I will not be discussing
specifically how to
interpret the various
asymmetries in
the landmarks in
order to arrive at
a specific pelvic
somatic dysfunction
diagnosis.
You will learn how
to do this later
on in a lab prep
lecture and lab
portions for the
pelvis. So for now,
just understand why
we perform the various
tests and how to interpret
them and you will
later combine this
understanding with a
discussion on the various
landmark asymmetries
so you can ultimately
diagnose pelvic
somatic dysfunction.
In order to come to a
conclusion of a particular
somatic dysfunction
for the pelvis, one
needs to check the
pelvis anteriorly and
posteriorly. Although
these diagrams appear
like they're standing,
to check one should
have the patient supine
to check for the
anterior landmarks and
prone to check for the
posterior landmarks
that would be the
easiest approach and by
heights of the landmarks
we mean any vertical
asymmetry in other
words it's one side more
cephalad than the
other sometimes we say
higher or lower but it's
best to use anatomical
terms how do we know
which side to name well
we name it based on the
side of the standing
flexion test because
the standing flexion
test tells us which
side has the pelvic
somatic dysfunction make
sure the patient also
sits the pelvis first
before comparing the
sides because as you
can imagine if someone
just lies on examination
table they might just
unknowingly be lying
in an awkward position
where any asymmetry is
due to just the virtue
of how they initially
lied on the table
so therefore one has
them bend the waist and
the hips and knees and
gently lift the buttocks
off the table and
lower it back onto the
table and straighten
the legs. And this
tends to normalize any
artificial asymmetries.
When you check for
landmarks, it's also
important to have your
dominant eye over the
person's midline and use
your thumbs or fingers
on the same landmark
in the same relative
position of the landmark
and make sure that,
for example, if you're
using the thumbs
underneath the ASISs,
that they are both
oriented horizontally.
Otherwise, if one thumb
is angulated upward
or downward, meaning
cephalad or caudad,
then it can artificially
give you an impression
that one side is higher
or lower when it is
in fact not that case.
Here we have two
pictures of examination
of landmarks.
On the left, we
have examination
of the ***** rami.
The finger pads are
placed on a superior
aspect of the *****
rami in order to
look for any unleveling
of these landmarks.
Again, you name
it based on a side
of the positive
standing flexion test.
On the right picture
we have the providers
thumbs placed either
just below or just
above the medial malleoli.
I find it typically
to be more convenient
to place it inferior
to the malleoli with
the sides of the
thumbs flush against
the inferior aspect of
the medial malleoli.
Keep in mind that the
medial malleoli is a
relatively accessible
landmark and any
unleveling can imply an
imbalance of the nominate
bones but the person
might actually have
a true leg length
discrepancy and that can
also cause unleveling
of the medial malleoli
so it is a useful
landmark and typically
will support or be
consistent with your
suspected nominate
diagnosis but it doesn't
always do that and part
of the reason could be
because of an actual
leg length discrepancy
keep in mind also
that if a person
does not have a lower
extremity on one side
or the other or there's
a cast, for example,
on one leg, then this
landmark is not
accessible for comparison
and it actually is useful
but it's not critical
for you to use in
order to come up with
an inominate somatic
dysfunction diagnosis.
Here we have additional
landmarks. I stress
the importance a
proper hand placement
and during practice to
both observe and palpate
these landmarks over
time you will find
that perhaps your
sense of palpation is
actually more gives
you a clearer idea than
even observing but it
is important to develop
both skills and you
name it for the side
that has the positive
standing flexion
test so there's nothing
intrinsically more
abnormal if it's
superior versus inferior,
it's, again, you
name it based on
the side of the
standing flexion
test, if there's
any asymmetry.
So if the standing
flexion test is on the
left, and it's superior
on that side, then
you call that side a
superior. So left PSIS
superior, for example.
But if it's the
right side that has a
standing flexion test,
you can call it left
superior PSIS, but it
makes more sense and
more efficient for you
to describe it as a
right-inferior PSIS.
Please take the
time to complete the
following self-practice
questions on your own.
These questions
will give you
a chance to test
your understanding
of the material
presented.
The answers
will be posted
at the end of the week.
Good luck, and thank
you for your attention.